as a kid because I'm trying to imagine
you imagine you as a kid you're you know
like probably really into comedy I'm not
saying were you a good student no
terrible student terrible student
terrible student I had long hair and I
looked and I had like a beard I look I
thought I was looking like kind of cool
I look like Charles Manson and I was
like goofy and kind of you know I'll
just kind of way I'm now just kind of a
goofball but every I had terrible grades
because I didn't really apply myself I
like wasn't interested in a nice stuff
and everybody thought I was on drugs
everybody and then you know like I had
like this cool I have this cool English
teacher he was kind of like Donald
Sutherland in Animal House you know like
that guy
yeah like tweed shoes and there's a
tweed suit and they're kind of like hey
man you know and and and these guys were
talking to him over in a corner and he's
looking at me and he was talking and
then he got I think he wanted to buy
drugs from me and these guys were like
they'd he doesn't do drugs and the guy
yelled out he was hater
you don't smoke the doobage I don't
smoke the doobies he's like oh it's too
bad man
smoked the doobage and read how together
away from me man